welcome to the the final session of this
particular CCA the second CCA of the
2014-15 academic year as with most ccas
we finish off with a faculty roundtable
discussion again a chance to reflect on
and talk a little bit about things that
we've heard things we've thought about
things that we've learned through the
last three days so thank you for coming
again please feel free to ask questions
at the end of this well the way this
format works is that we will have each
of the four of us will give a few
thoughts for on the order five to ten
minutes each and then we'll have
opportunity for questions from the
audience which those questions again as
before you'll have microphones that will
be brought to you so please if you do
have a question raise your hand someone
will come with a microphone and then
feel free to direct your question to any
one of the panel members or just to the
panel in general and then we'll we'll
pass it around okay and we'll we'll
definitely planned in by five o'clock
okay first of all let me introduce
myself my name is Mark nice bum i'm
professor and chairman of the chemistry
department here at hillsdale also though
perhaps more to the point i'm dean of
faculty and therefore serve as a
moderator for these CC a roundtable
sessions again it provides us an
opportunity to just think about things
we've heard and reflect on them and
offer some some feedback to one another
so as you all are aware the topic of the
CCA has been energy and associated
issues and controversies very timely
topic as it turns out as many of you may
have already seen there's been news that
came out just today about a agreement
that was made between President Obama
and the Chinese premier to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions well for the
u.s. anyway reducing pledging to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by 26 to 28
percent by 2025 which is certainly a
more stringent target than had been
proposed at least by us members in the
past of course it remains to be seen
what will happen with that once it gets
to Congress but again it just
this is a very timely topic so the week
CCA accomplished as we look back at the
variety of speakers that we've had and
the talks that have been given I think
it's safe to say that the this week CCA
accomplished what Ken Green and his talk
said that this panel of speakers would
do that is we have been educated
infuriated and entertained not
necessarily in that order now I won't
delve into all the topics deeply but I
did want to recall a couple comments
that seemed to me a particular interest
and just touch on those and then I'll
introduce our other speakers on sunday
night and mcilhenny was entertaining and
animated if you were here i think there
was nobody in the audience that fell
asleep it was very dynamic entertaining
she was all about what she preached
addressing the culture getting on
Facebook in the cultures public eye in
movies chat sessions selling the story
the political position really I would
say she makes a great fracking
commercial uh-huh and she urges us in
her talk she urges us to join her she
even says that conservatives need to
stop and a quote putting our energy into
logical arguments and pay more attention
to the culture for a good portion of the
audience that hurt her especially those
of our guests that are that are adults
that have been out in the marketplace
for a long time that's a message that
resonates and is practical if the goal
is to promote a political agenda then
her approach serves that purpose well
and that's arguably part of the goal of
the CC a-series but for our students and
faculty and especially students who are
here now think first that what we are as
an institution at Hillsdale College we
are first and foremost an academic
institution our students need logical
arguments careful consideration of facts
to draw well reasoned conclusions they
aren't in a position at least not yet to
go out and push an agenda they are in a
position where they should question and
learn from multiple perspectives
as much as they can about true energy
and environmental issues potential
solutions costs and benefits and
relative risks we owe it to them to
provide forums where quality information
representing thoughtful honest
consideration of the facts reasonable
concerns and options are weighed and
considered and the better we do that the
better they become at pursuing truth and
defending Liberty Robert Bryce said he
was agnostic whether co2 is good or bad
but he he said and I quote I'm tired of
the tribalism so I was deciding whose
side you're on us versus them and I
couldn't agree more I believe he
mentioned in his talk for ours and I
think on one of the climate change
websites there's three hours so in the
spirit of keeping with the arse I'd like
to propose my own three r's related to
the climate change and energy issues
conversation and my three RS would
simply be respect reason and reserve
there are intelligent moral thoughtful
people on both sides the climate change
discussion it is unfair and demeaning to
label those who disagree with us as bad
people or extremists or climate tests or
deniers or idiots surely we know better
I'm conservative Christian myself
generally vote Republican teach at
Hillsdale College most everybody who
knows me would label me conservative yet
i'm also a scientist and a chemist and i
am convinced as most of my scientific
colleagues are by scientific evidence
that there has been unprecedented
increase in both global temperature and
carbon dioxide concentrations in the
atmosphere over the last 200 years but i
will respect those who are unconvinced
and are willing to look at the evidence
and discuss it rationally also I
appreciate Bryce's point I think he made
a very good point when he said that we
need to move beyond looking at just
reducing emissions and focus also
perhaps more importantly on the big
picture which includes that but also
includes the need for reliable
electricity
the economic development prosperity and
realistic options and risks no matter
what we do there are no routes that
avoid problems and risks and we need to
look at the costs and benefits of all
reasonable scenarios but thank God for
those who disagree and challenge along
the way with respect are thinking it is
by doing so that we sharpen one another
and hopefully in energy terms generate
more light than heat so now let me move
on to introductions of the remaining
speakers of the round table and they'll
go in this order so I'll introduce all
three of my fellow panelists and then
let them go from one to the next so
first dr. ken Hayes professor of physics
and chair of the physics department here
he's been here since 1989 earned his PhD
in physics from Stanford in 1980 he also
served as a scientific associate at CERN
1981 to 1983 and a research associate
and staff scientist at the Stanford
Linear Accelerator Center 1983 to 1989
also dr. Kevin slack assistant professor
in politics earned his bachelors from
Indiana University in 1999 his MA from
UC Davis in 2003 another MA from
university of dallas in 2006 and his PhD
from the university of dallas in 2009 he
joined us on the faculty at hillsdale
last year and then finally Charles steel
associate professor of economics at
Hillsdale College holds the Herman and
Suzanne Detwiler chair in economics he
received his PhD in economics from New
York University in 1997 at NYU he
stuttered under study excuse me I'm
stuttering he studied under professor
Israel Kerzner leading scholar of the
Austrian school he has taught economics
at the graduate and undergraduate levels
in china russia ukraine national
university excuse me in qiyam oiling
academy the United and at the United
States at Montana State University and
of course here he has also worked as a
private consultant on design and review
of USDA crop insurance programs
2012-2013 steel was involved
excuse me was a visiting scholar at the
institute for health healthcare policy
and aging research at rutgers and he has
very recently been appointed to the
board of policy advisors of the
Heartland Institute his current teaching
here at Hillsdale includes resource
economics history of economic thought
mathematical economics and Austrian
economics his current areas of research
include the economics of healthcare and
economics of human trafficking all right
so let me turn it over then to our first
panelist dr. ken Hayes
I have a 10 minutes and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to show you data I'm
not going to show you the results of any
climate models I'm just going to show
you data and the elephant in the room
during the whole CCA was wait a minute
if we burn all these fossil fuels aren't
we going to continue to damage the
climate and the speakers did not address
that issue and so I'm taking it on in
this 10 minutes to address that issue I
gave a talk on the physics of the
greenhouse effect on campus last
Thursday and I don't have time here to
do that talk again I would like to do
that talk again here but I just don't
have the time so we're just going to
look at some data all right if you go to
Google Images and I surely hope you can
see the graph there because we're going
to see about 10 of them and I if you
can't maybe you want to get up and move
closer to the screen if you go to Google
Images and you type in the search phrase
the most famous graph in science this
becomes up on the top of the list and
that's called the Keeling curve that's
the most famous graph in science if by
that operational definition is to what
comes up in the google image search and
it shows the carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere from
1957 1958 when charles keating began
measuring the carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere on a
mountain in hawaii up into the present
time when he started the carbon dioxide
concentration was about 315 parts per
million by volume and this year we've
passed 400 if you look at the general
shape of the curve you see it's growing
and the rate at which it's going up
is growing on top of that you see these
are wiggles and those little Wiggles are
the kind of planet breathing during the
seasons when it takes in carbon dioxide
and then releases carbon dioxide if the
northern us on the hemispheres were were
symmetrical you wouldn't see it so much
but they're not most of the land is in
the northern hemisphere and so most of
the land sees winter when the northern
hemisphere sees winter so the bottom
line and the numbers is that the current
co2 concentration is 400 parts per
million by volume the pre-industrial
value there's other ways to recover what
the co2 concentration was prior to the
time Charles Keeling so to precisely
measure it and before we started major
human industry it was about 280 parts
per million and that represents a forty
three percent increase you can look in
ice cores in Antarctica and see that it
has never been this high in the past
eight hundred thousand years this is a
graph of the average surface temperature
over the earth for a year it's the air
surface temperature from about the time
we had the earth sufficiently
instrumented with thermometers that you
could talk about majoring such a thing
and so we're starting here on this graph
from 1880 and we're going up to twenty
thirteen and let's see people usually
talk about anomalies meaning differences
from a temperature value you get more
precision if you think of differences in
temperatures and trying to come up with
the absolute temperature so we all these
graphs i'll show you would be in
differences these particular differences
are from a base period of 1951 to 1980s
so you figure out what the average
temperature was in that Ares from 1951
to 1980 and and compare all the other
temperatures to that and if you look you
see the temperature has been increasing
it's been increasing rapidly the last
few decades and over the 20th century
it's gone up
about eight tenths of a degree c you may
wonder where is 20 2014 going to appear
on that graph the last date of birth is
2013 and 2014 is going to be the highest
data point on the graph this is the
global temperature anomaly for each
month in 2014 and for there's nine
months shown the last month to September
and 46 of those months the temperature
is an all-time record high so you can
extrapolate the last seven weeks 2014
and 2014 will be the all-time record hot
year the last 12 months is the all-time
record hot last 12 months but not only
people like to think of from january to
december this is a graph of the
temperature anomalies in September the
month of September over the whole
surface of the earth and if you look at
Michigan air fine Michigan on the map
you can see the Michigan's a little bit
cooler than the average and for the last
year it's turned out that Michigan has
been a little bit cooler the region
around Michigan has been a little bit
cooler and we've you know how to rough
winter last year but the planet as a
whole has not this is the last 50 years
of data taken from the birth berkeley
earth surface temperature study and this
is my graph and i analyzed that data to
see if i could see any evidence that the
rate of warming has slowed down or
paused I've done data analysis for the
park ad group since 1984 and I have a
lot of experience and I know how to
answer statistically questions like that
and there's no evidence in this graph
that there is anything but a linear
increase in temperature general increase
in temperature you can't make a super
strong statement with this graph because
there's a lot of noise in this graph you
can see that some data points are higher
than the linear trend and some are lower
there's a lot of noise in this graph
and that noise is mostly heat being
transferred from the atmosphere into the
ocean and vice versa but there are a lot
of other majors you can make that have a
lot less noise than this so you can put
the hypothesis to the test of whether or
not there has been a pause in the
warming by looking at some of those
other majors so let me show you some of
the other majors in my presentation last
Thursday to the campus I spent about
half of it trying to explain the physics
as to why the land really doesn't play a
role in determining you know where the
heat goes as the planets warming here's
a where the heat went from 1970 12 2010
and you see the vast majority of it like
93% of it went into the oceans the land
just doesn't play much of a role a few
percent went into melting ice and a few
percent whether the continents about 1%
one in the atmosphere so if you want to
answer the question with less noise is
the planet still warming how's the plant
warming look at the oceans that's where
most of the warming is going so one way
to look at the oceans is a look at the
sea level rise and there's been a
satellite a series of satellites
actually that since 1992 have been
incredibly precisely major any average
sea level rise of the oceans so this is
a graph from the erisa colorado at
boulder showing the sea level rise from
1992 to 2014 and it has much less noise
in it than that previous graph the
average surface temperature graph and
you can see by the trend of the ocean
the sea level rise goes up when the sea
level goes up when it warms because the
thermal expansion of water when you heat
water that's above 4 degrees C it
expands and if you melt ice and the ice
melted ice it's on land the water flows
into the sea it goes up those are the
two largest contributors to the sea
level rise there's also we've been
pumping water from fossil aquifers and
that's measurable in terms of its
contribution to sea level rise and
that's a smaller contribution so there
you can see there's no evidence there's
any slowdown the Seas just warmin pretty
much at a constant rate over since 1992
you can also made you the temperature of
the ocean and here's where 3577 Argo
floats are as of today at various places
in the ocean there's a photograph of one
of the Argo floats on the right and
these things for about the last ten
years have been they go through these
10-day cycles where they drop down to
about 2000 meters and then they cruise
around a little bit just being carried
by the currents and then they rise up
and they slowly rise up and they measure
the temperature the salinity and the
pressure is they rise up and I get to
the top they transmit their data by a
satellite and they repeat the process so
this is the total ocean heat content
measured by our goal in the last ten
years and by previous generation prior
to our go before that and other
techniques and you look at the last 18
years oceans are warming there's no
evidence at all that there's any pause
to the warming you wouldn't expect to be
you wouldn't expect it to be any pause I
mean we understand very well what's
causing the warming we understood
greenhouse effect has been understood
first calculation of how much you expect
the Earth's surface temperature to rise
if you double the co2 concentration was
done in 1898 by a Swiss chemists to
eventually won the nobel prize in
physics in chemistry so we've known
about it for a long time there's no
mystery here here's another data set you
could use there's a beautiful pair of
satellites called grace the gravity
recovery and climate experiment and this
is just a beautiful idea you take these
two satellites and they follow one
behind the other in orbit and the
distance between them is measured very
very precisely there's a new generation
of this going up in 2017 it'll mace the
distance 20 times more precisely than
the grace satellites
and when they approach a mountain when
they go over a mountain on the in on the
Earth's surface the front satellite
pulls ahead because it's attracted more
strongly to the mountains gravitational
attraction and then when the rear
satellite trailing it catches up goes
over the mountain it catches back up and
so by measuring that distance very
carefully in doing an analysis you can
measure the mass of the mountain so the
mass of the mountain that's called the
Greenland ice sheet has been measured
very carefully since 2002 when grace
started collecting science data and if
Greenland wasn't melting this line would
be a horizontal line with some Wiggles
if Greenland wasn't melting this line
would be a horizontal line with Wiggles
its measuring the mass loss in Greenland
in gigatonnes and you can see the mass
loss in Greenland's accelerating and the
precision of the measurement is so good
that you can see the difference between
summer and winter you can see you know
in the winter when the mass of ice grows
and then in the summer when it melts off
you can see those and you see the rate
is accelerating if you look at the
right-hand curve you can see that the
equivalent effect on sea level rise and
it's contributed something like seven
millimeters of sea level rise since they
started making these measurements with
the Great South Greece satellite in 2002
here's the Arctic sea ice this is the
Arctic arctic sea ice volume measured
from 1980 he goes to a big cycle every
year which is its minimum around
September and then grows and grows and
then starts heading back down towards
this minimum you can see the whole cycle
here from 1982 2014 and if you look at
the minimum Arctic sea ice around
September compare it from 1882 you know
the last few years it's about one-third
of its value compared to what it was in
nineteen eighty and if you just
extrapolate follow your eye along the
bottom of the curve down and you'll see
if you extrapolate with your eye by
around 20 20 within a few years of
twenty20 there will be no
arctic sea ice in September and that
will increase the warming of the planet
because the the ice reflects very well
the sun's light that hits it and the
water beneath the ice when it's exposed
absorbs the sun's light very well so
there'll be an additional contribution
to the heating of the planet when that
arctic sea ice melts and when amounts of
course it's like 24 hours a day sunlight
on our i love the Arctic almost done
here is a graph of the difference in
temperature between the North Pole in
the equator the difference in
temperature between the North Pole in
the equator from a 1948 20 August 2011
and you see that that temperature
difference has been dropping the last
couple decades it's been dropping now
the atmosphere is a heat engine and you
know all the winds come from it comes
from temperature differences so there's
these jet streams that swirl around the
poles and they kind of isolate the
arctic air from the air like over us and
as that temperature difference drops
because the Arctic is heating a lot more
rapidly than the equator then that heat
engine has less energy and the jet
stream slows down and that slowed down
on the jet stream allows these big
Wiggles to form in the jet stream and so
you hear about this thing called the
polar vortex which allows cold air
masses to flow from the Arctic down over
for example us Michigan that's going to
happen this weekend it happened a lot
last winter and winter is just starting
and here it is happening again so the
climate is changing very very
dramatically we can't keep doing what
the speakers at this ccaa you know told
us we had to keep doing we can't so
there are a lot of people who were
thinking of how to get out of this
problem i just have three books here
i'll just show you and then i'm done oh
i guess i do not going to show you
here's one of them it's called
reinventing fire by a wonderful guy
named amery Logan's
and he says you know fire made us human
and fossil fuels made us modern we have
to find a way to reinvent fire and
that's what this book is about thank you
lament the fact that the person that I'm
replacing isn't here professor young in
the chemistry department but I will try
to contribute my best I'm a professor of
politics here at Hillsdale my first
point is drawn from the Hillsdale
student who asked Stephen Hayward quote
how do you separate the science from the
politics my answer is that when science
enters the realm of politics it's no
longer science because politics is the
realm of opinion politics is the realm
of opinion in at least two ways the
first is the most obvious do you know
the facts for most of the population the
discussion will remain at the most basic
level do you believe in global warming
on this level I wish I could have seen
and think it would have been good for
our students to have seen a round table
with two climatologists engaged in a
scientific discussion about the
available data and models and then
perhaps address why they've adopted
different political opinions but even
this would perhaps conceal how politics
which couples science to policy issues
immediately distort Sciences namely
science becomes a source of authority
rather than a mode of inquiry science is
the quest for the unchanging politics is
the realm of the changing the virtue of
the first is wisdom the second is
prudence we've all seen how science is
used by politics scientists make
ambiguous statements which pundants and
media translate into declarations which
politicians respond to and feed more
money to scientists who make ambiguous
statements etc yesterday I asked a
friend of mine an environmental
scientist who studies climate for an
opinion about popular treatments of
climate science the response was I quote
if it's not by science writers it's
invariably crap have yet to find someone
writing intelligently about climate
science and quote my second point when
we forget that science and politics have
different ends we start to think we can
unite them every student here is read
Plato's Republic in that book the
ambitious Glaucon who longs to see
perfect justice concludes that the best
political regime is the rule
of the philosopher yet the just City
that he creates is a place where no one
would want to live it's a tyranny that
expels all art music and even philosophy
itself Socrates saves the city from
Glaucon by directing him away from
political life we find that the greatest
impediment to the perfectly just society
is precisely the difference between
science and politics the philosopher
does not want to rule the American
founders agreed none but God they said
was perfectly wise and good hence none
but God justly is given absolute power
standing before a courtroom in 1761
James Otis quoted John Locke's teaching
of the limits of the legislature to rule
only by standing promulgated laws to
rule only for the public good and not
for a particular class no taxation
without representation no delegation of
lawmaking power to another body because
men are not angels the new constitution
of 1787 limited government through
separation of powers and checks and
balances the American progressives
rejecting the scheme of constitutional
government believed that the
contradiction between science and
politics could be resolved they promised
a rule of bureaucratic experts not
unlike Plato's philosopher Kings they
would place via a new science of
administration Socrates on a regulatory
board to solve labor disputes and set
air ambient quality standards my third
and final point the rule of the supposed
experts and energy policy has led to
three great and justices that the
Constitution was designed to prevent
first amidst fanfare at the federal
level Congress in 1970 Clean Air Act
delegated its lawmaking power to the
Environmental Protection Agency to
identify the most important pollutants
promulgate clean air standards and with
state cooperation set in motion their
reduction to healthy levels by 1977 but
what is the result of the delegation if
you realize that the act was the
brainchild of the auto industry which
was searching for a way to minimize its
state-level regulatory burden and a
federal agency like the EPA that
provided exemptions was the best way to
do this hence most of the EPA's go
run met by 1987 and many by 2007
Congress under the guise of deferring to
the wise experts in the EPA was able to
punt on making the hard moral decision
between protecting health and the
economy Congress could take credit for a
popular goal achieving clean air but
leave the means of achieving that end to
the EPA more so it could blame the EPA
when voters complained about the
unrealistic cost of its proposed rules
as well as blame the EPA when it had
failed to achieve clean air on schedule
only when voters began to blame Congress
did it make the hard costly choice by
passing the clean air act amendments in
1990 which instituted an operating
permits program the state's themselves
arguably did more to clean up power
plant emissions in the 1960s than the
EPA accomplished in the 1970s after the
Supreme Court's 2007 decision in
Massachusetts v EPA that the EPA must
regulate greenhouse gases under the
Clean Air Act we should expect similar
promises and results the EPA will
achieve astounding environmental goals
with little impact on the economy
government on the one hand will improve
technology and on the other hand place
the burden solely on big business rather
than the taxpayer but the real question
is how much are you personally willing
to pay for lower co2 emissions and is
the end this is not a scientific
question it's a political one secondly
the administrative state replaces the
rule of law for exception to the law
because Congress has not passed laws but
suggestions today administrative
agencies are given the power of
lawmaking enforcement and adjudication
according to the progressive this would
allow for flexibility experts could
apply regulations on a case-by-case
basis this is also Madison's very
definition in Federal's 47 of tyranny
regulations are not promulgated laws no
one can know them it's not just the
sheer volume of thousands of regulations
it's the nature of regulations the EPA
responds more to internal pressures than
to the public need for clear laws the
agency defines its powers as broadly as
possible and then qualifies it's obvious
overreach of power while
setting a multitude of narrowly defined
exceptions neither are they standing
they vary so quickly none can keep up
every business is in violation of some
environmental regulation more recently
even the fiction of law has been
abandoned Michael grieve and his article
administrative law without Congress
shows that agencies frequently rewrite
environmental and energy and energy laws
thirdly regulations are not applied
equally those with connections are not
prosecuted exempted from regulation or
given special favors Green Energy
thrives on such special favors one need
only look at the stimulus and exemptions
given to green energy companies many
going bankrupt those subsidies grew from
500 million 25 billion between 2007-2010
after issuing global warming rules in
January 2011 the EPA exempted a General
Electric subsidiary from air quality
standard standards in February wind
energy is exempted from paying fines for
600,000 birds that windmills kill each
year under the Migratory Bird Treaty Act
killing just one bird carries fines
ranging from 15 to five hundred thousand
dollars in prison terms of six months to
two years oil and gas companies have
large exemptions last year the EPA
exempted one oil company which it did
not name from the renewable fuels
mandate the 2005 energy bill the
so-called quote Halliburton loophole
exempted fracking oil and gas companies
from seven major federal environmental
laws thank you
great thank you I want to first thank
say thanks to Matt bell into the
organizers to my fellow panelists and
especially to you guests and students
for attending this conference I want to
look at these issues from an economic
standpoint I'm going to go fast but I
think it's important to note that a
couple of the two very well known
economists were recently at a conference
became involved in a very heated debate
it was not resolved on the flight home
they found that they were seated on the
airplane together one at the aisle one
at the window and so they resumed their
discussion and after a couple of minutes
the gentleman in the middle said look
I've been on an international flight for
ten hours now I've got two more hours
I've got an important presentation to
give after we get get down and I'm not
getting any sleep can I please change
seats with you guys and so one of the
Economist says are sure gonna go sit by
the window and so they look at they
trade places the Economist look at each
other and one says you know that's the
first time in economics discussion has
kept anyone awake and now you know why
I'm last in the line up here at any rate
I'm going to give it very fast thank you
fast big picture view as i see it of
what we what we're dealing with here and
one thing i want you to keep in mind as
i do is this question how do free people
solve problems and i'm going to start
with some basic facts and number fact
number one is that we humans are in a
process of building a world civilization
100 maybe 200 years from now this is
going to be obvious it may not be
obvious now and I won't predict what it
will look like but I'd be very surprised
if it did involve a big world government
I don't think it will but i do think
we'll have an integrated civilization
second one of the most important parts
of this will be economic development
right now the majority of the world's
population lives in less developed
countries and they will develop in fact
they're doing it now it is happening
just as an aside what continent had the
highest rate of growth a per capita
income last year if we compare Africa
and Asia and the answer is Africa
for the last decade or so Africa has had
per capita income growth of four to six
percent annually that's the basket case
so we're there is economic growth
development is a fact and it will
continue and it will grow third energy
production and consumption will greatly
increase worldwide both total and per
capita the two gentlemen from the
Manhattan Institute already made this
abundantly clear and they are right and
my fourth fact is that this growth will
certainly be accompanied by increases in
greenhouse gas emissions that's
inevitable and again I think Bryce and
Mills made that point pretty clear now
we can say something about the us-china
agreement after after the during the
questions and answers that's may be
relevant here but there are four facts
and the conclusions that I draw from
those are first of all that development
and energy worldwide will increase in
civil greenhouse gas gas emissions great
well what can eat an economist say about
this let me gives an economic analysis
yeah and first I refuse to offer a
professional opinion on anthropogenic
global warming a man-made climate change
because that's outside of my
professional training I will simply note
that the vast majority of relevant
scientists appear to accept it and they
make fairly persuasive cases for it
economists historians etc should be very
careful about they should be very slow
to argue with physicists about physics
at any rate I'm going to simply take it
as an assumption or if you prefer a
working hypothesis that the expert
consensus is right and if you reject the
hypothesis that's great that's fine I
simply want to ask what if it turns out
we're wrong how would free people solve
this problem so there's the assumption
we're going to assume for at least from
the moment that anthropogenic global
warming is true and that it's dangerous
so let me do a little bit of economic
analysis if I say to you increased
energy is good most of you are going to
say yes
and if I'm addressing a climate change
conference and I say to them most of you
agree that reduced greenhouse gas
emission is good they will say yes and
you know something you're all right so
there's a trade-off there and it would
be foolish to maximize one of these
things at the expense of with no regard
at all for the other both have to be
taken into account is what I would say
if we can reduce greenhouse gas
emissions that's good but at what cost
in terms of reduced energy reduced
income and reduced human well-being and
if we can increase energy production
that's great but again at what cost in
terms of a worsened environment damages
and reduced human well-being so there's
the economic issue a trade-off how do
you solve the question and I think
economists have about three different
kinds of broadly speaking solutions to
this and the first one is central
economic planning I'm going to just stay
without explanation that that's to be
rejected and if you want the explanation
you come and you are welcome to take my
austrian economics class next term
everybody's welcome we'll explain it
number two is regulation I'm going to X
I'm going to reject that when I without
explanation if you want to know why
revisit professor Grossman's lecture and
professor slack just said something
about that and I like I could say more
but I'll skip that one what can be done
how do free people solve problems like
this it's a good question what's the
nature of the problem well to an
economist this is a problem that's often
called an externality but what is an
externality it's a failure of decision
makers to take into account some very
important consequences of their
decisions now why the heck would they do
that well prices communicate costs and
the communicate benefits and for some
reason these benefits are that are being
excluded are not being considered in the
market price okay well why is that that
could be shown in a long economics
lecture that at the root of the problem
there is assess is this because of
incomplete property rights and at heart
I'm willing to our
you all environmental problems stem from
this so what solutions are there and
what do I propose actually I don't
propose anything i will say that there
are possibilities and i want to ask how
my own time right now Moke a couple more
minutes i will just say that a couple of
a number of free market economists have
made various proposals that would help
better define property rights and give
decision-makers the right incentives to
take things into account and i can give
a couple of examples but the problem is
every one of them has costs and everyone
has benefits just in just an example ed
Dolan and an Austrian economist and
libertarian has suggested a system under
which you'd have strict liability rules
for aunt for anthropogenic global
warming damages is argued for this both
on this stick from the standpoint of
Justice and I mean real justice not
social justice and also for economic
efficiency reasons Roger miners Bruce
handle both of them property rights
economists have talked about the use of
common law rules for nuisance and
trespass and how they could be
potentially used in controlling air
pollutants and air pollution problems
Greg Mankiw former chief economic
adviser to George W Bush is talked about
the possibility of tax the taxes on the
emissions that is on the bad part of
things to create incentives if they're
done right they could work there are
others and I don't endorse anything I
simply note that there are possibilities
for solutions that we did improve the
property rights of regime all of them
have benefits and all in half cost now
this is the Ludwig von Mises lecture
series so I think it's now time that we
pay a little bit of attention to what
Lisa said this is meeses the decision
about any proposed measure is to be made
on the ground of a meticulous weighing
of the costs to be incurred and the
prize to be obtained no reasonable man
could possibly question this rule so
here's my conclusion what's the bottom
line of this first of all we need energy
we need development and we don't want to
wreck the environment
we want to find ways to make these
trade-offs in such ways that we make
things better not worse economics tells
us that any time we see a sub optimal
situation such as an externality it is a
potential profit opportunity if you act
on it correctly you can actually create
net benefits but that means something
else that means that potentially this is
not a zero-sum game potentially this is
a positive sum game if we approach it
correctly it can potentially be win-win
if we approach it right and that I think
is why it's important the people on all
sides of the climate debate and the
other energy issues approach this
approach these issues carefully
thoughtfully respectfully and especially
with a positive sum mentality and I know
that there are wicked people out there
who have adopted climate change for
example as a you know for as a Trojan
horse for ulterior Regent reasons and
another anti global warming activists
who are simply mindless but there are
also a lot of very good people
thoughtful reasonable people who I know
who are deeply concerned about the
climate issue and they do have that
positive some mindset so here's what I
think I think we should be thinking very
carefully about what can we say to them
about how free people would solve these
kinds of problems and get a reasonable
trade-off between the two goods at hand
now I've got quite a few numbers here to
quantify this but is my time up time is
up this is the end of the economics
lecture so time to wake up
alright thank you dr. Steele thank you
Phillip each of the panelists now we'd
like to open it up and again we don't
have enough time but I would love to
have as many questions as we can handle
in the next 15 minutes or so so if you
do have a question please raise your
hand and again the young ladies with
microphones will come to you and wait
until they come to ask your question and
again you can address your question if
you would like to any particular
panelist or just to the panel as a whole
thank you really thank everybody for
coming out today they professor
specifically for speaking to us in this
faculty roundtable my question is going
to be for dr. Hayes it's going to be
talking mostly about the boulder study
and what was the methodology behind that
study and watch we prefer it that's my
first half the questions second half of
the question is what is the role of
government in this issue and what can
government do to help or maybe you did
like what is the solution to this
problem in your mind thank you sir the
boulder study of the sea level rise it
was been a series of three satellites it
uses a microwave signal that gets sent
down and they time the reflection very
carefully you measure that distance
knowing the speed that microwaves travel
you have to know your starting point
very well so the satellite position has
to be known very very well in the
position of the satellite its altitude
is known to a precision of about two
centimeters and you just do that over
and over and over and monitor the height
of the Seas about the proper role of
government I don't study that I will not
offer any I don't have any special
wisdom I simply will not answer
aside from the fact that Obama as usual
exceeds his constitutional authority
what what uses it to try to curtail co2
here when all the co2 increases come
from China India and the Southeast Asia
belt that's where the increases are what
can we do about that well again I think
as dr. Steele mentioned we're seeing
more and more and I think he would say
although I don't put words in his mouth
we're seeing more and more international
debate and discussion and for example
today some sort of agreement between
Obama and Chinese premier but may think
it's true that we obviously in the
United States can't control what goes on
in in other countries per se however
it's also true that United States while
our rate of growth of co2 emissions is
not you know not as bad as it has been
in the past and we're seeing some real
improvements with the use of natural gas
I mean there's still a lot that we can
do in this country again not just
looking at emissions but just as just as
our country has done and many times in
the past for example during the
Depression during World War two you know
when when faced with a situation again I
don't want to call it a crisis but let's
say space with a situation with need
which in which we need to calculate
costs and benefits and respond
accordingly and do things like for
example be willing to sacrifice certain
certain desires for certain other
longer-term desires for example as you
know as people were very no proactive in
terms of conserving fuel recycling doing
things like that during the Depression
and then also of course during the war
years there's a lot that that people can
do that can make a difference in terms
of what this country is doing and again
if
if we can take away the well look at the
u.s. look how bad they are I mean if we
can continue to we've shown people as a
country we've shown how innovation can
can lead to tremendous advances in
energy development and innovations and
lots of different technologies so it
makes sense for us to lead the way even
even if and I won't say this is
necessarily true but even if it were
true that we were doing everything right
and the co2 emissions in the US are
coming down and in China and India and
everywhere else are going up even if
that were the case we would still be
setting an example that I think others
could follow which I would love to see
us do to at least some extent I don't
know if Charles unfettered with it is
this on is it okay I so a couple of
answers that I were a couple of things I
would say they're not answers what can
we do well first of all these are
international issues by nature what
we're talking about it's a global global
issue but still ideally if this is
understood properly it is a win-win
situation it's just very hard to do but
it but it really is positive some second
thing I'd say that international
negotiations matter and so does
international trade just one thing I
would think of for example is what about
increased trade of Technology it's not
in the interest of third-world or
developing countries to wreck their
environments this is in their interest
as well to get get problems under
control technology in the United States
is some of the cleanest available
technology in China is not trade that
way could actually improve Chinese
technology it's a win-win kind of thing
something else I'll say and I was kind
of joking about having a lot of numbers
but I do have one that's sort of
interesting because World Bank has come
out with a study the economics of
adaptation to climate change since
synthesis report was kind of interesting
and one of the things that they talk
about one of their their primary
recommendation for between now and 2050
they say economic development is perhaps
the best hope for adaptation to climate
change adaptation is important second
thing they say is that the cost of doing
this is this is a ball
figure would be something like a hundred
billion dollars a year potentially it
can save maybe again these are I quote
these numbers without having study them
a trillion dollars a year in damages but
this is a potential win-win thing and
there's got to be ways to work out deals
on these sorts of things my questions
for dr. Hayes in your lecture on
Thursday you he stated the ninety seven
percent at all scientists hold global
warming and then we heard dr. Hayward
references the study he found that said
that a third of all side I seven percent
of a third of all scientists say that so
just to clear up into that contradiction
just hear your response on that surely
in my lecture I showed you a couple of
slides one of them that showed a partial
list of national international
scientific organizations that you know
make statements in support of the IPCC
statement on global warming I also
showed you a list of national
international scientific societies that
made statements opposing it and that
list was empty there are none there have
been multiple studies of the fraction of
peer-reviewed climate scientists who
under sign on to the consensus that that
I presented to you here just with data
and Naomi Oreskes has done one of the
earlier studies and she also gets 97%
she does a very different study than mr.
Cook so the vast majority of
peer-reviewed climate scientists accept
the story that I presented to you last
Thursday
may also respond to that the if if you
go back and I don't know if you can can
listen to mr. haywards talk again I
think correct me if I'm wrong but I
think what he said was that in that
particular article which again was
looking at climate change articles he
said that of the of the scientists who
well let me back up again he said all
right what was the number of scientists
who reached an opinion in their article
about climate change and there were
something like sixty-seven percent of
the authors of those articles that were
looked at didn't have an opinion or in
that in that particular article didn't
express an opinion either agreeing or
disagreeing with say a particular
position on anthropogenic global warming
and then he said about thirty three
percent of them did express an opinion
and of that thirty-three percent
ninety-seven percent were in agreement
with it so that's where I think you got
the figure of a third was that of that
of the articles we're assuming of the
references that were looked lat in that
particular study only a third we're
expressing any sort of opinion about the
issue that he was of interest it was
interested to him and of that third
ninety-seven percent were in agreement
with it so again that he's looking at
the the selects articles that were
quoted in that particular study and
again there is nothing there that would
suggest that there was a large number of
scientists who disagreed with it it's
just in that large number of articles
that were looked at they were quite
quite a few articles that didn't involve
expressing an opinion on the subject
only thirty-three percent did another
that thirty-three percent ninety-seven
percent we're going to greement so again
it's a little bit I don't know
disingenuous perhaps or at least a
little bit of the old statistics don't
lie but they don't sit
well again that that use of statistics
again is is probably somewhat accurate
but again it's not not giving you a
result that is very meaningful because
again that's simply saying that there
were 60-some percent of the articles
that were referred to that weren't
expressing an opinion I just add a word
huh thank you thank you yes you can
publish all kinds of articles involving
some aspect or another climate science
where it's not your result isn't a
statement of whether or not you're
agreeing with you know the general
consensus on global warming it's just
some particular detailed measurement
you've made and you don't make any
statement which is what Mark was saying
and that's what those statistics meant
it didn't mean that the people didn't
have an opinion the two-thirds of
climate scientists didn't have an
opinion and they were like neutral to
the question it just meant in those
particular papers the issue didn't come
up that's that's what mr. Cooke Matt
newspaper thank you hi my name is Gabby
I'm a senior at the college my question
is actually for our two scientists now I
understand that the earth is roughly
about 4.6 billion years old and the data
that you've presented today and all the
data that I've ever seen about global
temperature increases and the oceans
rising and things like that have been
from the past 50 to 100 years of data
data which is I think we can all agree a
blink of an eye in comparison to 4.6
billion years and I understand that
industrialism has had a huge impact on
the environment that humans have a huge
impact on the environment but is there
any evidence to suggest beyond the past
fifty to a hundred years that is simply
isn't or this is not simply a trend or
that you know we're not doomed and that
the global temperature won't naturally
decrease in the future um
there's all sorts of evidence that
extends over much longer periods than
just the instrumental temperature record
which I showed today you know we didn't
get the earth covered with thermometers
with a sufficient density that you could
talk about something like that average
temperature of the surface of the earth
until about 130 years ago but there's
all kinds of indirect ways you can
measure the temperature of the earth in
my talk last Thursday I showed you a
beautiful way involving filling holes
into the ground and measuring the
temperature is a function of depth in
that hole and if the whole has nice
properties the rock is you know pretty
uniform as you go down you don't run
into any big aquifers and rivers and so
on underground you can reconstruct the
temperature back a thousand years or in
the very best hole like 2,000 years if
you dig down in the ice in Greenland you
can go down to about a hundred thousand
years and you can accurately measure
through proxies the temperature where
that ice was in Greenland back for about
a hundred thousand years if you do the
same thing in the deeper I scores in
Antarctica go back eight hundred
thousand years so that statement you
know that the co2 level that we have
today is is not been exceeded on the
planet for the last hundred thousand
years is comes from ice cores if you
want to go back further there are other
ways involving sediments I won't spend
any more time on it but there's a lot of
data in the past now the earth's
temperature has changed dramatically
over the past and co2 concentration in
the atmosphere has also changed
dramatically over the past what's unique
about this particular change is it's way
faster than anything that we've seen in
the record it's way faster than anything
that's happened naturally and that is a
terrific problem for the biosphere
because you know the biosphere is a very
cup tightly coupled interlocking system
and if if things get out of sync if
flowers are blooming for the bees are
ready to pollinate them if if you know
all these things don't happen in a nice
synchronized way there's going to be
real trouble and we we are in apparently
the sixth interval of major species
extinction in the history of the planet
right now we're in the sixth one yeah
there's been five before and they
certainly run caused by us I don't think
you would have wanted to live in any of
those five and you probably aren't going
to want to live in the sixth if we don't
bring things under control
my name is Will Crockett I'm a freshman
here I've got a question for dr. Hayes
you mentioned that actually demonstrated
very well that temperatures are rising
in the past 50 years or so and you
pointed out that we can see a increase
in co2 levels when we look at ice caps
and what not but like you also said
there's been a lot of major temperature
changes in the world including what made
the dinosaurs extinct and I was
wondering what evidence you can give us
that this one is certainly caused by us
and not just another one of those
friends thank you well first off what
made the dinosaurs extinct 65 million
years ago was the impact of a large
asteroid it had a lot of iridium in that
asteroid and you can dig down anywhere
you wish pretty much along the surface
of the earth and go down to the layer
that corresponds to 65 million years ago
and you can see the Iridium layer left
over from from that asteroid collision
they'll also wiped out something like
ninety-five percent of the life on Earth
65 million years ago and it wasn't do
necessarily immediately to a temperature
changes due to the large object
colliding with the earth maybe you saw
the fact that a mountain-sized object
passed right near the surface of Mars
about three weeks ago one through the
distance between the Earth and the moon
and NASA have three or four orbiters and
a couple of Rovers on the surface which
try to make measurements of what
happened when that being passed so close
and so long history of that in the in
our own history so how do we know it's
root cause net well there's a lot of
different ways one you can their
fingerprints that is you can try to
imagine other things for example you
could imagine let's say it's caused by
the fact that temperature you know the
energy up of the sun's going up okay
what would you see if the energy of the
Sun was going on well you'd see that the
temperature during the day was rising
you know more than it was when its
temperature the Sun was cooler because
the sun's energy comes
during the daytime when it doesn't come
a night in fact you see the temperatures
at night rising from what they were
before and that's because the co2 in the
air is taking the reflected thermal
energy coming off the surface at night
and reflecting it back down to keep the
nighttime temperatures high that's an
example there's a whole set of things
you can do to verify you know the
understanding of what's causing this
particular increase in the earth's
temperature and all works out perfectly
I think we're going to need to close for
the sake of time however any of you that
would like to are certainly welcome to
stay and talk two panelists individually
afterward thank you very much